awesome uh so how many of you have heard
about this format known as SAR
one two three four five six oh nice okay
so this is gonna be your introductory
talk about
this is going to be introductory talk
about how Za Works using some neat
illustrations Annex
a bit of a code to show how job works
and I'm gonna try to convert the Czar
logo which is a PNG into Czar format so
we're gonna have we're going to select a
lot of things to do
so this is today's 19th of April uh we
are at pycon uh Germany and Pareto
Berlin 2023. it's
235 236.
a little bit about me uh I take care of
the community community and the open
source software of Zar as their
Community manager I have been working
with them since one and a half year
before that I have shared six to seven
padida conferences these are these are
mostly paita Delhi and parita Global
conferences I before and apart from my
volunteer time I've worked with
forensics startups organizations in
government of India and when I'm not
working I like to play violin any any of
the violin players here string
instruments oh nice and if you like this
talk you can go to my Twitter handle I
know it's this looks looks scary looking
not as scary as this guy
yeah this is this is me uh this is my
photo in a pixel pixelated version
so yeah
uh if you want to look at the slides in
the code this is this is the link you
can just go ahead and take a screenshot
uh I'm sorry there's no there's no QR
code uh you know Miguel
um
yeah cool
so what I'm gonna about to show you like
what is our and how it works uh then
there's some couple of like few lines of
code and like obviously like why you
should use it like there are so many
data formats out there and why you
should choose why you should use or and
how it is different and then we'll come
to the specification part which is uh
more of like a technical thing I mean
yeah obviously because it's a pycon yeah
and then we can talk about
implementations in community
[Music]
um so that was basically created by this
person known as Aleister miles he is a
scientist at Oxford so basically he was
working with genomic data of mosquitoes
and their data sets were like in large
size like 100 of GBS and petabytes so he
needed like a way to how to handle and
manipulate the data efficiently and
without losing any information so this
was created in 2015 and if you go to
this link this basically in the 2015 it
that's the link of the first comment in
the project and as you can see uh on the
bottom there's like the Twitter handle
the GitHub link and the website uh it
has like a rapidly growing user in an
industry base uh people have been using
it like I mean NASA if I have to start
with then Microsoft Google and Amazon
and all these companies uh and Tsar has
like implementation in several languages
like python Julia C C plus plus
JavaScript
but this is like pycon so I'm gonna
talking about only the python
implementation of SAR which is our
Python and currently it has 21 code devs
uh yeah it is sponsored by num Focus so
no focuses
and it's funded on this season I
seasonize like the non-profit arm of
Facebook and EOS stands for essential
open source software
so yeah enough of that
uh so yeah before working before uh
yeah before uh zaal let's have a look at
what Aryan tensor is I'm sure like
everybody know what a rent tensor is
here right
okay so we can just I can just skip
through these illustrations which I have
made uh not made like this is by this
person was Trevor so like array is like
a container of items like how you should
how you contain your data like you have
like 1D 2D and Andy and
it should be like it could be like 8 bit
16 bits 32 bits or 64 bits and uh like
we have these Dimensions like 1D 2D and
3D so Zar is actually an specification
which is actually a technical document
of how the array should be organized
your hierarchy should be grouped how
your metadata should look like and based
on the specification we have like
implementations in different languages
and the specification basically lays out
how you can store your data in chunked
which is basically divided compressed
you can compress those chunks and in
dimensional manners yeah so on a lot of
technical terms but I'm going to
simplify it in the in the in the next
couple of slides
uh so let's just say you have like a
small data set to work with you have
like one GB of data you can easily load
it into a laptop and you know work with
it because you have that much memory in
your computer but let's just say what if
your data is too big to fit in your
memory like let's let's just say it's
like 100 GBS you can't just load it and
work in it so you need something which a
data format which could work out of the
memory so that's what basically Czar
kicks in and what it does is basically
divides your array into equal chunks uh
as you can see that the equal chunks
have been divided over here and it
compresses all of these individual
chunks using the using compressors in
the num codex Library num cortex is like
a dependency of Tsar which is under
these are developers organization and
this like compresses like block zsd zlib
and LCM and all the compressors that you
can think of
and you can own you can so all these
chunks are compressed and these chunk
these compressed chunks are basically
stored in your hard disk not in your
main memory and you can work and you can
retrieve those things that you want to
work with into your into your main
memory and then you can make some
addition make some subtraction manage
manage those things and store them back
into your main memory and the reads and
the rights are basically concurrent so
if you have like if you want to work on
multiple chunks at the same time you can
do that as well
uh so this is what the uh a group like
Czar group looks like this is the this
is actually a container as you can see
the uh
um this part over here is the actual
data which is the binary blob and on the
top of it it's we have this metadata
metadata so Z zra stands for the zra has
basically all the uh important essential
information about your Tsar array what
compressor did you use how many chunks
you have what like which along which
dimension did you chunk your data and uh
other information and z address is
actually the custom attributes that you
can add to your data set which could be
something like like the time of the data
was taken like who created this data and
how it should be accessed and what's the
uh I don't know like password or
something and the Z group is basically Z
group is actually uh when you
so when you have to store like multiple
arrays into hierarchies the Z group
attribute will still with store will
store how these all these different
areas are organized in the hierarchies
um so yeah so this is a simple uh what
you call it uh
illustration of how the chunking works
and how this decompression works so we
have this like we have we have this
n-dimensional big area we have divided
in four chunks and each chunk would be
assigned a key
using mutable mapping fashion in Python
and every every chunk would have key and
all and this chunk would be compressed
using those that num codex Library which
I showed earlier and
you can if you want to work with the
with any of the chunks you can just
enter the key and that that chunk will
be retrieved not the whole data so let's
just say if you're working with like 100
GB of data and you want to just load the
last chunk you don't need to like load
the whole array into whole whole data
set into your memory you can just
retrieve that chunk and work on it
and yeah so this is how the uh the whole
cycle of like compression and how does
the uh and
allotment of keys and values work
uh so yeah as I told earlier like there
are different type of compressors
available over here and the next thing
is the file storage system so they're
like different type of uh storage
mechanisms for your data on your disk so
you can use like sip store which is the
zip file you can use memory store in the
memory store like directory store which
is like simple fashion directory of how
you store files in your laptop or in
your system and then we have like cloud
enabled storage like AWS S3 FS uh sorry
AWS GCS and Azure so you can basically
directly talk to the cloud using our
interface as well
um yeah
so a few so this is the basically the
link of the uh code Google collab
notebook if you want to have a look at
it uh I'm gonna switch to my node my
notebook my Jupiter notebook
is it visible is it visible to everyone
okay
how about now
okay cool uh so I I assume everyone is
familiar with numpy so I'm gonna just
skip the introduction to numpy uh like
how to create an array in numpy and how
to slice it and everything uh so
this is what this is how you can
basically create arrays inside using the
create function so here we have
identified the shape of the array which
is like thousand by thousand
and I have identified the chunks like
how how many chunks I want to basically
split that that whole big array into it
and the D tab is actually the data type
which is the float and this is the store
I want to use like the location of my
data set uh and if I run it and that's
now I can see like the mazara is stored
and uh it has like 1 10 000 chunks
because thousand by thousand unit
divided thousand by thousand into ten
you get 10 000 chunks and as you can see
like there is no chunks initialized
because you haven't written anything on
it so there's like your memory is
entirely free right now there is it is
not utilizing any of your memory and you
can see like the so I haven't mentioned
any compressor over here because uh I
don't want to because it's I have to
like finish in like population in a
limited time but as you can see like if
you don't mention a compressor it
default it defaults goes to block and
this is the total size of like 7.6 MB
how much data it shows it's storing and
I just use this this is fill values
actually like the note uh I want to see
like what's the value written in it and
when I try to access the uh like the
first chunk it shows like 0.0 the
address is 0.0 and now I want to
basically write uh two like the scalar
value 2 into the into the into half of
the chunks and when I do it like uh you
can see uh like the half of the data
half of these chunks are initialized and
it's now taking like bytes storing so
now it's storing like 210 KB into a
memory and that and the above like the
number of bytes is the actual size of
the whole whole chunk and uh yeah all
the other information that you can see
and in the next we go I try to attach
some uh custom attributes to the to my
data set like if I want to add something
so here I added like unit per second
unit units like meter per second and
standard name like win so this is what
basically I have so for from for what
I've done so far is I created an array I
wrote some data to it I added some
attribute to it but what is what does it
look like under the hood so this is what
the hierarchy would look like so you
have this uh these small binary blobs
with the uh uh the key from 0.0 to uh
50.0 and then you have this Z array
which is actually the uh this one and Z
actors is actually the attributes which
I just wrote it to my uh sorry
and if I try to open the Z array you can
see like everything which is everything
which is uh
written everything everything which was
created when you created your Zar array
and if I try to open the Z adders like
you can see like how the uh
attributes are being shown which I just
wrote it to my data set and earlier I
talked about the hierarchies like how
different type of hierarchy different
type of arrays are stored in a hierarchy
so I just tried to create like a group
over here and you can see like how this
uh this has like a parent and children
and Children of Children so yeah you can
see like how these structures are these
are basically structured like in store
multiple uh arrays multiples are arrays
in a hierarchical manner and you can add
as many attributes and as many as many
uh data to it and uh yeah so I also have
this small
yeah
so yeah as you can see like you know
everything is just uh organized in a
neat fashion for accessibility and for
you for for you to work with it uh now
I'm gonna just try to uh I mean I've
already done it but I'm just gonna try
to show it so I'm gonna try to convert
like a pixelated logo of SAR which is in
PNG format to actually XR format which
is actually the extension known as SAR
so I try to load an image uh so this is
something I made uh myself uh with the
you know because I do some pixel art and
I try to load it and it looks like this
and then I convert basically this image
into a numpy array uses using the as
array function and when I converted it
so I can see like the type is the numpy
ND array and the shape and what does it
looks like and now when I have to
basically convert it to zare I just need
to basically pass it past the numpy area
over here into this Zord array function
and as you can see like it just gets
converted and I didn't I didn't so
there's there's uh I mean in the earlier
code I basically
[Music]
um
yeah I basically uh indicated the shape
and the chunk and everything but if I
don't do anything like if I just pass
the array uh it's capable of you know
doing everything on its own and so over
here I just created derivative dot
specifying chunks compressor or the
shape and everything and it does
everything on its own and you can see
like the data type and the number of
chunks and so there are essentially four
chunks and and you can see like the how
much size it is taking like on the disk
and everything and I try to basically
attach the attributes like I just showed
before uh and you can see this uh custom
attributes which have attached attached
the uh the pixel this is our pixel logo
and if I
um yeah so this is this is basically me
just trying to visualize these R array
which I just created and yeah so if I
have to show you like how does it looks
like uh
so this is this is what we have just
created so this is actually the logo of
the Czar so this is just the image and
it has if I do this I have this zra file
because it's like hidden so I can just
hide it and yeah so this is actually
your image and you can store any data
like any data you have like as large as
like DBS and I'm gonna show like a
sample data set of 54 terabytes which is
stored on Amazon AWS and this is yeah
this is it so your data is like uh
stored over here and you can convert any
data using Tsar in in this manner and
this is the data that we have earlier
that we have created earlier which is
the 10 000 by 10 000 chunks so how this
is how the chunks would look like and
this also has this z r and C address
file at the top
okay coming back to the slides
uh yeah
yeah so uh
okay so why you should use a chart
because uh there are a couple of reasons
that I would like to uh show you like
you can chunk arrays along any Dimension
so the chunking that I've done was
basically the default chunking and but
you can chunk across any Dimensions like
across across or vertical or horizontal
or beneath the depth and Aries can be
written concurrently from multiple
threads and processes and this is really
helpful when you're working with a large
data set across cloud or in local
machine it's easy to extend like The
Styling is mostly similar to numpy like
how numpy works and the compression
support is like really great you can use
any compressor and the num codex is
actually uh dependency of that so yeah
uh and uh simple so the last point is
simple it's simple and it's open
specification which allows it to be
hackable uh so the specification
basically is open source which allows
anyone like you can just you can just go
home and try to implement Czar into a
own programming language and it would
work easily so everything is like just
open uh and like when you when you
should basically use so when you have
like absolutely large data sets so let's
just say if you are dealing with a
hold on yeah so this is like a nice
graphic so let's just say you're dealing
with this 120 terabyte of file which is
in Tiff format so this is like a big
monolithic file you have and let's just
say if you want to access the middle
part which is highlighted in the middle
and how would you do it like you have to
basically load the whole
whole big monolithic file into your
memory to work with it but if you have
if you have like a format which is which
has chunked your data sets into like
small small chunks you can actually
access the data set using that key which
I showed you earlier in the illustration
work with it and then store it back into
your main data set and you have this
attributes and all these stuff which you
can basically work with
um yeah and if you want to share your
data set I mean essentially I think this
has been case earlier like people have
used people have used you know hard disk
and Pen drives to actually share itself
physically from one place to another but
having like a chunk format like
something like Zar makes it very easy to
share about clouds cloud storage and
yeah I mean this is like a illustration
like I've sometimes like in like earlier
people have to like use actually
download the whole data set if they want
to work on it but yeah that's not the
case now like you can you can just
retrieve those things that you want to
work with
um yeah so this is the if you want to
see more illustrations uh like these one
like you can go to this link uh this was
amazed by this person was Henning Fox
which the name you can see at the bottom
so yeah you can take a picture also
[Music]
um
yeah so just a little bit about
specification this is the uh technical
specification which is actually provides
the protocol it has is anyone familiar
with web standards like what web
standards are w3c protocols like how
basically internet works and how
basically two points talk to each other
so this is so specific specification is
something similar like that and you can
uh go to this link at the top and you
can see the specification So currently
version 2 is an effect and we have just
released version three which is going to
be out in like a month or so so it has
like really really good uh What do you
call it support for extension points so
extensions are extensions are something
which you can basically add without
without losing the existing capability
of SAR I can talk about it more uh after
the talk
uh so this is uh so yeah just coming
back to like what the what does the
beauty of Zara means so this is on the
left hand side of your image this is
like a 54 terabyte image of an
oceanography this is like sea surface
temperature and on the right side this
is the microscopic image of the covid-19
infection in lungs and this was this is
basically like everything is uh you can
uh you can go into slides and you can
check this out and this was basically a
visualize using this Vitesse um I don't
know if I'm saying the name right but
you can see on the the top there's a URL
and this is basically a visualized
visualizer for n-dimensional arrays so
this whole data set is in czar and
uh yeah you can see like how beautiful
is like you know take a moment
uh yeah uh just to talk about
interoperability I think we folks are
familiar with what task and x-ray is
right
so you can you don't you don't need to
basically installs out to user you can
use R through x-ray and task as well you
can open your desire data sets using
task and you can write to it as well
uh so these are the implementations I
was mentioning earlier like you can see
Java C Julia JavaScript so you don't
need to just I mean python user to user
you can use R through any other language
as well and yeah it's severally like
easy to implement Zar from scratch so I
think we are lacking R sorry no rust and
go implementation so if any of the folks
want to give it a try feel free to
uh yeah and Tsar Community is like
everyone who loves Zara who works with
tsar and if you're a user if you're a
developer if you're just a occasional
contributor you're welcome I'm the
community manager of Zara so I take care
of everyone who is inside the community
and who basically wants to contribute
and we have just developed this no it's
been a year that we are working through
this process known as zip which is this
which is the basically similar to pep
but it just was our specification how
the changes should be incorporated into
bizarre specification uh what does V3
looks like it's mostly uh
uh change in the metadata and how the
chunk should be handled but it's this
revolutionary like we were trying some
benchmarks earlier and it's been super
fast since the V2 and if you want to
join or get join our guitar you can just
go to the link at the top at the bottom
uh this is our guitar Channel which is
also like an open source open source
Communication channel
uh these are some of the data sets which
are on the cloud right now like CM CM
ip6 which is the uh public data set of
the uh climate model this is like uh one
petabyte and the neck on the on the
right hand side of the screen you can
see this is the sea surface temperature
I think this was hosted by NASA yeah
this is hosted by NASA it's it's also a
54 terabyte in total and this is like
one singles or store so you don't need
to like actually uh load this 54
terabyte data to work with it like you
can just load few MBS or few GBS to work
with it but you can just go I can I can
share this share the data set of the
link of these data sets and you can see
have a look at this
um yeah I mean these are just some
things like uh if I wanted to show do
you have do I have time
okay cool
uh these are the some of the uh
universities or research groups or
companies who are using Czar for this
touring data set like uh engineer
Microsoft NASA and car ome stands for
open microscopy um and uh mostly the
the domains which basically produce
large data sets are geospatial
microscopy genome sequencing and data
science so these these fields have been
using Czar heavily for the last
five or six years
and uh yeah one more thing like which I
wanted to mention is like uh this is
like a very versatile format and there
have been development of conventions on
top of Tsar so you can see like I've
mentioned GEOS are over here so geosr is
actually the geospatial extension of
Tsar which actually fiddles with the
metadata to a level which is readable by
satellite and ome is always actually the
uh microscopic version of like how you
deal with microscopic images of NCS are
I think people are familiar with net CDF
net CDF data format oh yeah so NCR is
actually the extension of the net CDF
version of SAR and uh yeah I think
I think at that that's that's it that's
it for my side I may have rushed a
little bit but yeah feel free to join
our office hours and Community calls if
you want to learn more uh these are the
handles if you want to uh
have a look
yeah I mean
any questions
thank you very much for your
presentation
um so far I think we don't have any any
questions from slido but um
I think that's also no problem someone
else oh yeah maybe could you enter it
and slide already
yeah I'll just pause the microphone
thank you very much for the presentation
it was very interesting uh I'm just
trying to get a better understanding of
how uh compared to format I know
I'm trying to get a better understanding
of our Tsar compared to other formats
that I know so like you are talking
about choosing for very large data sets
so for instance if I have a large data
set of images I will store them as a
JPEG and if I have a large data set of
structured data I will store them as
Pockets so how does that compare to that
how is it better
yeah so uh so I so I mean I would I
would just ask you another question like
how how much larger like what's the
largest image size you have deal dealt
with I don't know a few Millions
sorry few Millions
no I was talking about image like what's
the largest size of the image or jpeg
you have dealt with
how many images you mean no like a
single size of the image sorry uh yeah
like I don't know 1000 by 1000 something
like this
yeah so that would be somewhere around
500 MBS or it may be basically I'm not
sure about this side sorry yeah
basically it was easy to load in your
memory right yes yeah so I mean your
laptop didn't crash when you were trying
to load it but let's just say if you
ever emit size so I was just showing
this single image
yeah so this single image is like 30 GB
if you try to load it in your memory
it's just gonna crash it so you need
like a chunked format which you can
easily load the uh essential part of the
data set you want to work with and then
you can store it back and I mean you
don't need to like actually uh load the
whole image to visualize it there are
like multiple visualizers like n
dimensional visualizer have you heard
about napari napari there is like uh
neuroglancer they basically visualize
your n-dimensional areas no matter how
big it is on the web browser
so very clear sorry I didn't see that
slide I was uh yeah no worries
I will go to next question
so uh question how does the performance
compare to just using a numpy
uh performance like in Watsons
you're you want to perform some
operation over this array you want to
find the sum for example
I mean uh I haven't done any benchmarks
yet but I think it's quite similar
because uh zarpool's numpy is one of
their dependency
I hope that answered the question I will
move on move on
uh what types of data do you think Czar
is potentially not the most suitable for
um so I think uh the one of the uh well
when I see in the GitHub issues and all
the stuff people have from from the deep
learning and the Machine Learning
Community have been coming to us and
they they they were thinking like how
they can store their csvs and pack a
files which are like very big and mostly
the uh as I mentioned earlier the
domains which are
which are which are using Zar more R
deep geospatial genomics and microscopy
not the Deep learning and machine
learning folks so I think like uh this
is this is the question that needs to be
answered and this is I think answer for
your question as well uh I haven't
experimented with I haven't experimented
myself experimented myself but I think
this is this is like a big question mark
if it can handle like CSU and back here
Road data sets
um in the meantime we got one question
um from slido and this is how the star
compared to pocket
I was sorry okay so then I will move on
sorry
thanks for the talk um yeah we've also
been using uh and it's awesome
um I have a question concerning the
version three because I think version
two has some issues when you store very
small chunks on cloud storages with uh
yeah which have high latency so we're
really looking forward to version three
and my understanding was that there's
the specification which seems to be
rather final but no final implementation
or only I only for like experimental
ones so maybe you can clarify that
because yeah yeah for me just give me a
second so I have this issue already open
on my laptop
yeah so this is the issue which was
created two weeks ago and this is the uh
final what do you call it final
uh checkpoint to the completion of the
zip one which is actually the version
three of specification zip is actually
the Czar enhancement proposal and the
first step was the V3 specification and
if you have to uh I can uh you can take
a picture also like if you can see the
link and on the bottom you can see there
is the uh this implementation which is
the closest implementation of the V3
specification which is known as zarita
so you can have a look at this I can
share the link with you after the talk
and this is the uh this is like the
Prototype implementation because V3 is
still in the review and it's going to
take like a month or so to complete the
review and just implement it in Saw
python but there is also a with
implementation in Java python as well
but it has but there's a technical Gap
because the VP implementation was
implemented last somewhere around July
last year and there has been changes to
the specification a lot since then
because we have been developing the
specifications since
two or three years so this is zarita is
the closest one if you want to try V3
and after V3 is finalized you can
actually jump back to Zar python which
the with the actual with implementation
cool yeah thanks a lot
so thank you very much I think we have
to close the session right now
um I think if there are any more
questions you will be happy to answer
the questions on uh in in person or via
your channels you showed in your talk
thank you very much one more round of
applause for something to stop
foreign